from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between monster energy in the uk and the
us this is food wars
[Music]
officially speaking classic monster
energy only comes in one portion size in
the uk a 500 milliliter can i looked
around for other sizes online and i
thought i'd found some 440 milliliter
cans
but unfortunately the seller just sent
me a bunch more regular cans
only on food walls are we annoyed when
they send you more than you paid for
classic u.s monster energy comes in two
sizes the standard 16-ounce cans or the
mega monster energy can which is 24
ounces good
lord that's 710 milliliters a 42
increase of the largest uk can this is
too big this looks like the canister of
ooze that fell in the sewer and made the
ninja turtles when you buy other monster
products in the uk however some of them
do come in different sizes to the
classic can for example an espresso
monster can in the uk is just 250
milliliters certain monster ultra
flavors come in a 553 milliliter mega
can and if you get a bottle of monster
hydro sport it comes in a 650 milliliter
bottle the type of monster energy you
drink also affects the can size in the
us java monster cans come in 15 fluid
ounces and the rehab monsters come in
cans of 15.5 fluid ounces 16 is too much
15.5 print it
what about the largest multi-pack item
by volume one in the uk it's a 12 pack
of monster hydro sport
which totals 9.75 litres of monster it's
quite a lot
that pales in comparison to the us's
largest multi-pack that's 24 pack of
16-ounce cans a total of
11.365 liters of monster and that's 16.5
increase of the uk multipack i didn't
get it but it is at target so here's a
video of me holding it up i thought i
was taking a picture that's me realizing
that oops is on video
[Music]
here are all the monster energy products
you'll find in the uk including those
that you won't find in the u.s here are
all the monster energy products in the
u.s including a bunch you won't find in
the uk not only are we going to talk
through all these but we're also going
to taste them and provide some thoughts
oh i'm dead
i'm dead
i mean i barely survived the mountain
dew episode so
if you would have thought by now in food
wars i would have learned my lesson you
would think wrong let's start with just
the classic monster energy drinks in the
uk we have two flavors that you won't
find in the us we could only get one of
them today and it's this one the lewis
hamilton 44 monster energy lewis
hamilton is a formula one driver he's
one of the best ones of all time he's
got i think seven world championships
and when he races he wears his lucky
number which is 44. so they partnered
with lewis to create this drink let's
give it a try
[Music]
it just smells like red bull i'll be
honest
it's probably a good time now to say
that i don't actually drink energy
drinks i barely even drink coffee i very
loyal to tea so
this is gonna be fun cheers
it's just quite a standard energy drink
flavor but yeah it goes down pretty
smooth i wonder if this would make me
faster if i drank it the other exclusive
uk monster energy flavor is vr-46 which
unfortunately i wasn't able to track
down today the vr46 can is designed in
collaboration with valentino rossi who's
a very famous gp driver i'm sad i can't
get the cam today because it gave me
enormous mario sunshine vibes
also i need to stop drinking this
because i've got a lot more monsters to
try
we have a few exclusive monster energy
drinks in the u.s at the monster energy
low carb
oh i hate how that smells like i
instantly have a headache
this has to be the first time in history
someone has poured monster energy drink
into a cup and not drink it strictly
straight from the can right who's ever
done this before
it tastes like electricity
next up we have the monster reserve
watermelon and the reserve white
pineapple oh
it tastes like sparkling juice i guess
there's like this flavor of like
static i got this one this is the
monster import super premium what is the
is 18.6 fluid ounces but look at the top
on this one do you understand how to
open this
oh here we go
this to me is like maybe don't drink
this all in one sitting
while in europe of the spanish moto gp
we saw a cool resealable can and it'd be
perfect for monster the canned company
said only available in europe we said bs
we gotta have it whoa monster with the
attitude if you could open and close the
can with one hand you probably dated a
lot when you were younger
i mean everyone who's drinking this is
12.
how european the next category is juice
monster well in the uk it's juiced
whereas in the us it seems to just be
juice we do share most of our flavors
with the us in this category but we do
have one or two which are different
we'll start over here with ripper
when i first saw the cannon the name i
thought it was like based on australia
because you like you little ripper is
like a kind of australian saying but
then i read the can and it turns out
it's actually based on hawaii and surf
culture
sometimes you want to just throw a
shrimp on the barbie and say you little
ripper
oh
this one smells nice
i've sipped like two of these and i have
a headache already so this is going well
then we have one which seems to be a
linguistic difference in the uk you can
find juiced monarch the can is adorned
with loads of butterflies and monic is
of course a type of butterfly whereas in
the u.s you guys have papio which is
french for butterfly so i'm not really
sure what they've gone for there
obviously the uk has a monarch so maybe
we've just gone for the kind of royal
theme on this one who knows
oh i actually like that one
oh no this is bad i can't like these
i'm not ready for an energy drink era
our juice monster drinks come in two
exclusives the juice monster pampeon
butterfly themed like uk monarch
i mean i don't want to keep drinking
this but if i had to i wouldn't be as
upset aussie lemonade style
it's like i'm surprised these don't have
alcohol in them because it smells like
an alcoholic beverage
actually i do like this it's not bad it
tastes like lemonade
like i'm drinking it doesn't feel like
i'm also like getting energized to fight
next up we have some coffee and monster
hybrid beverages in the uk on the
website it shows us espresso monster and
these include espresso and milk monster
vanilla espresso monster and salted
caramel espresso monster however if you
click the buy now link it takes you to a
page which doesn't actually seem to
contain any espresso monster so i'm not
sure if they've been discontinued or not
i was able to track down the espresso
and milk monster on the internet
to be fair that just tastes like a
coffee i don't get any kind of like
monstery elements from that which i
think is a good thing the pace at which
i talk is just going to increase and
increase throughout this episode we have
the coffee monster in the us too however
over here we call it the java monster
and there's so many flavors got the java
monster mean bean the loco mocha
kona blend the irish blend the local
vanilla lights the salted caramel the
swiss chocolate the cold brew latte the
cold brew sweet black the farmer's oats
vegan coffee and the 300 triple shot
mocha and 300 triple shot french vanilla
i of course got the 300 triple shot milk
milligrams of natural caffeine oh go to
hell robust coffee plus cream all this
cream in this says shake it up
so i'm shaking it
why did it have me shake it up
why did i have a shake it up
if you're at work and you see any one of
your fellow employees walking in the
morning drinking one of these uh you get
like it's time to find a new job because
that guy is going to flip out
bad
is there a napkin somewhere
next up we've got monster hydro support
now these are a range of non-carbonated
energy drinks which are kind of targeted
at athletes similarly to a powerade or
gatorade style beverage in the uk they
come in three flavors charge striker and
hang time i've only got the charge
flavor today you can find the other ones
on the internet but we're gonna give
this one a try
it's got a really strong slightly
chemical smell to it
but the taste actually isn't that bad in
the uk we drink a lot of squash which is
kind of like a concentrated juice thing
that then you dilute with water it just
tastes like a kind of strong squash
we're making a mess
all right
monster hydro sport energy water for
advanced hydration
okay they have a bunch of these this is
the tropical thunder
okay
and it looks exactly like gatorade oh
oh this is bad
there
purple passion
this one's like really bad but like the
second it touched my lips i was like
i've made a mistake other hydro flavors
include super sport killer kiwi super
sports macho mango super sport red dawn
super sport blue streak blue ice
watermelon and hydro zero sugar aka
hydro white we have a couple of monster
product ranges you won't find in the uk
starting with the rehab monsters these
claim to help you quote refresh recover
and revive end quote after a heavy night
yeah right the two that i was able to
get my hands on are strawberry lemonade
and tea lemonade the lemonades
yeah no
yep looks exactly like the first piss in
the morning
maybe the worst one okay so we have
rehab monster watermelon you also get a
rehab monster peach tea an orange aid
and a raspberry tea i was actually able
to track one of these down on the uk
amazon website it seems to have been
imported from somewhere in europe i
think maybe italy
quite bad i'm at that age now where i'm
always hungover what about you harry
i'll be honest if i'm hungover i'm gonna
go for a giant full english breakfast
loads of salted vinegar crisps and then
about two litres of fizzy water instead
of one of these then our final exclusive
range is muscle monster these are
exclusive shakes with 27 grams of
protein and 157 milligrams of caffeine
you can get them in vanilla muscle
monster energy drink shake and chocolate
muscle monster energy shake i don't have
them it's probably a good thing
now we can't get muscle monster in the
uk but i'm pretty sure i can just
combine a standard monster with some
protein powder and it'll have the same
effect right
of many bad ideas that i've had
on this show this might be the worst
i'm gonna go with two teaspoons of
protein powder
[Music]
that's the good stuff
what on earth am i doing with my life
it's just currently kind of formed a big
layer
there we go
i hope you can see how badly this has
gone this is not mixed at all ah dear
god
oh god
i think the texture is more off-putting
than the taste it's just like drinking a
really grainy monster energy the things
we do for games am i right guys
monster energy products have some
ingredients that you might want to watch
out for but there are also lessons to be
learned about ingredients which sounds
scary but actually completely fine
here's the ingredients list as it
appears on a can of classic monster
energy drink i really haven't even
opened this yet cheers guys miss classic
master energy
oh it's poison here's the ingredients
list as it appears on account of classic
monster energy in the uk
let's start with the good news if you
take a look at the us list you might see
some scary sounding chemicals like
pyridoxine hydrochloride or niacinamide
which seemingly aren't present in the uk
drink
however these are actually just full
names for vitamins b6 and b3
respectively same goes for riboflavin
and sine cyanocobalamin
in the us list which is just vitamin b2
and b12 in fact when you go through the
list and add it a couple of other
linguistic differences you'll see that
the drinks are actually identical in the
two countries that's not the only thing
we can demystify about monster either oh
god i'm like stealing from all this
energy drink ah you may notice that
monster contains taurine for years
taurine has been the subject of some
inaccurate rumors on social media
inaccurate rumors on social media huh
turian's been associated with bulls
drawing its name from the latin taurus
some people ran with this and falsely
claimed that taurean is code for bull
semen you have to be an absolute idiot
to think that taurean is bullshitting
period the name taurean comes from the
fact that it was actually first isolated
from ox bile even more good news is that
there's no ox spit in monster energy
either as most food producers will now
use a synthetic version of taurine that
isn't derived from animals this also
means that monster is suitable for
vegans okay enough defending monster
what about the more questionable
ingredients some of the flavors of
monster energy drink contain
controversial food colorings for
instance all these four bad boys have
red 40 in them this is the visual
representation of children bouncing off
the walls so all these got the red 40 in
it let's do a power
controversial chemical taste test
bad
somehow worse
i don't know what flowers taste like
definitely not that
that's kind of nice actually this other
one that's sitting over here if you're
wondering why it's over here so i'm
talking like super fast all of a sudden
it's just really kicking in so this
section the u.s portion of this is
completely disorganized it's 100 my
fault this i just what i
what time is it these are food colorings
derived from petroleum they've received
a lot of attention in the past due to
concerns about their safety in 2007 a
study from uk academics linked to red 40
yellow 5 and yellow 6 2 hyperactivity in
children possibly adults and yelling or
5 to also being linked to causing cancer
give me a dancing rat sometime now thank
you
while these dyes aren't illegal in the
uk most manufacturers will still avoid
using them because if they are added to
food they must bear a warning label
which shows that they may have an
adverse effect on activity and attention
in children however as monster energy is
kind of designed to make you hyperactive
it's one of the uk products which still
uses one of them our pipeline punch and
ultra red monster energies contain red
40 listed on the ingredients as e129
which means that they also have to have
the hyperactivity warning the good news
for the uk is that we stopped short of
using yellow 5 and yellow 6 in our
monster instead opting to use carotenes
to colour our yellow drinks like mango
loco there was one other monster-based
controversy that came out of the british
isles the republic of ireland pulled
four varieties of monster from its
shelves including juiced ripper and
lewis hamilton 44 after they were found
to contain excessive levels of propylene
glycol propylene glycol no if that's how
it's pronounced is a chemical which has
gras
generally recognized as safe
status from the fda it's mostly used in
food as a humectant which is something
which absorbs water and provides
additional nutritional value it has been
the subject of some hysteria in the past
it's one of the main ingredients of
antifreeze is it can lower the freezing
point of liquids however this level of
it would never be found in food or drink
even the food safety authority of
ireland said that the products it
recalled were unlikely to cause any
harmful effects
let's talk about caffeine for a second
regular monster energy in the uk
contains 32 milligrams of caffeine per
100 milliliters which equates to 160
milligrams in a 500 milliliter can a
regular can of monster energy in the us
also contains 160 milligrams of caffeine
with a slightly higher figure per
milliliter than the uk as our cans are
slightly smaller that's roughly
equivalent to two shots of espresso
which usually contain around 80
milligrams of caffeine per shot if we're
talking per milliliter the uk's most
caffeinated monster would be the
espresso monster which contains around
60 milligrams of caffeine per 100
milliliters almost double the amount of
the normal can however the uk espresso
cans are only 250 milliliters that means
that a whole can of that contains less
caffeine than a whole can of the classic
version the most caffeinated us monster
drink
is the monster java 300 line which as
the name suggests contains 300
milligrams of caffeine per 15 fluid
ounces good god at what point does
caffeine intake become a problem the fda
says that 400 milligrams per day is
generally not associated with dangerous
negative effects but if you consume 1200
milligrams in a relatively short amount
of time that's when the toxic effects
like seizures can start to be observed
according to the fda the
life-threatening dose of caffeine is 10
grams of caffeine it's surprisingly easy
to get hold of pure caffeine online
without any age verification i was able
to pay 23 pounds for 100 grams of this
which is theoretically enough to kill 10
people we're going to weigh out a 10
gram lethal dosage just to show you how
little that actually is so that is
roughly what's in there
that right there is more than enough
caffeine to kill a normal human being
there's about four teaspoons worth
what's this like in terms of monster
energies well in the uk you need to
drink 7.5 of them to hit the 1 200
milligram mark but you need to drink
62.5 of them to hit the 10 gram mark
this means you'd be unlikely to digest
from the caffeine on its own but it's
not unrealistic that you may experience
some negative side effects if you
consume a lot of it it's a little more
risky here in the u.s just four of these
java 300 cans can put you at risk as
seizures although it'd probably take
33.3 of them to kill you yeah and you
wouldn't die from caffeine you'd die
from like your bladder exploding from
having 33 of these how many fluid ounces
is that what's 15 times 33 it's worth
mentioning that in some stores across
the uk they will ask for proof of age in
order to let you buy monster energy i
got id and a co-op trying to buy some of
the drinks for this video there's no
legal restriction on the sale of energy
drinks in the uk and they can
technically be sold to anyone but some
retailers will voluntarily cap them to
people over the age of 16. this is a
fantastic idea i'm not kidding we should
be doing that the age restriction is no
one over 25 drinks this crap you stop
drinking this when you get like
i don't know
responsibilities there's also a large
amount of sugar in monster energy in the
uk a 500 milliliter can contains 55
grams of sugar that's 110 of your daily
allowance a 16 ounce can in the u.s
contains 54 grams of sugar which is 108
your daily allowance now remember though
the us cans contains around 30
milliliters less than the uk can so
proportionally speaking they're
basically the same my uh my spit and
poor glass that i was using special uh
avella blend
it's not that bad
do you guys wanna try it